Hello,
and welcome to today's episode.
Today, we are taking a look at GetOps
and the GetOps toolkit.
And who better to join me than Stefan?
Hey, Stefan. How are you?
I
can't hear you.
Okay. Sorry.
Peter, there. I was like, oh, shit. What's
happened?
There we can hear you. How are you,
Stefan?
Great.
Very happy to be here and
share the
work we've been doing on the GitOps toolkit
and the road to FluxCDO.
Awesome.
Well, I think the the best thing for
us to do would best be to quickly
give an overview of what GitOps is.
Right.
So
GitOps is a way of doing operations
through a Git repo.
You define your state there, and it's happening
by magic on your Kubernetes clusters.
That's the key.
So we store our declarative state and then
get repository
and it is magically applied to our customers
for us. And to do that, we need
tooling. And you've got quite a lot of
experience in providing the tooling that actually makes
us work. So
I guess the sorry.
On you go. Yeah. We we started, I
think, three years, four years ago
with
Flux
as a way to run a daemon
on on the cluster
that can be configured.
You tell the daemon, hey. There is my
Qt repo. Here is the authentication for it.
Whatever you find in there,
try and reconcile that particular state on the
cluster
and
follow,
any other change
and also,
do garbage collection. If someone deletes something from
from Git, you also delete it from the
cluster. So it's more about
it's like a proxy between your, Git changes
and what's happening, inside the cluster without you
having to directly connect to the cluster and
perform those changes manually from your laptop.
Excellent. So
like you said, you you've been working on
Flux for a number of years now. And
and we're now at a stage where there's
the GetOps toolkit and conversations around Fluxv two.
Can you maybe just explain
what the GetOps toolkit is and where Fluxv
two kind of commence to the picture as
well?
Yeah. So the the toolkit, like like the
name implies, is a collection of tools.
Flux version one was this monolith that you
deploy and does a bunch of things for
you.
So we took Flux apart. We break it
down into microservices,
and we
then we'll be assembling back Flux from this
microservice.
And these are these microservices are Kubernetes controllers
built with Kube Builder,
and the configuration part of your whole GitOps
pipeline is made through Kubernetes custom resources
unlike Flux v one, which would you would
configure it with
in your deployment spec with common flags for
Flux.
So it gives you more, you know, freedom
to do a bunch of stuff.
Okay.
What is the the status of GetOp's toolkit?
I think there's been a fair number of
releases over the last week. The last time
we spoke, you mentioned the API was stabilizing.
I mean, is it in a position where
people should now start to to pack GetOp's
toolkit over Flux v one, or should they
wait a little bit longer?
So we
we've started with with the toolkit experimental
things
around six or seven months ago,
and we we've published a road map on
the website.
We
broke the road map into three milestones. One
milestone is get on future parity with Helm
operator. Helm operator is the component that deals
with Helm in a creative way.
And for
for the Helm features, we are at 100%
feature parity, the GitOps Toolkit.
So for people that are using today Helm
operator, they could
switch to the Toolkit and
have the same the same features there and
many other features
on top of that.
Regarding to Flux, we with with split Flux
into two milestones. One is Fluxing read only
mode. What that means is
where Flux connects to a git repo with
a read only deploy key, so it will
not commit back, do not write anything to
it. It looks at it and applies it.
And
for this milestone, we are
with in future parity in the tool kit
so you can use it today to synchronize
your Git reports.
And Flux has a has a feature
where it can scan container registries,
find a new image tags that you've pushed
there, and write those back to to your
Git repo based on some policies. For example,
I don't sample range or or Git Shine
zone.
And that particular feature is still under development.
So if you are using Flux today and
you are relying on the write back mechanism,
the image update mechanism, you'll you'll have to
wait more, probably till the end of the
year when we get that out.
For
for the helm operations and
git synchronization,
the current toolkit API is is no longer
alpha.
We we've published the v one, beta one
release last week.
And, yeah, I'm thinking it's it's ready to
go
for sure.
Excellent. Well, I'm very excited for today.
I'm also not the only one. We have
a comment from Ilya who says he's very
excited about Flux v two and the GitOps
toolkit. So
we're all we're all we're all really happy.
We're looking to see this. We all wanna
start using it. So let's let's just share
my screen and walk through the process of
how people can start to use the GetOp
tool kit today.
Cool.
Alright. So but there we go.
So I've gone ahead and configured as little
as possible upfront.
Of course, we need a Kubernetes cluster. So
I spun up one using the cluster API
on Equinix metal and it is good to
go.
Let's run get nodes to make sure I
haven't broken anything in the last five minutes.
Excellent.
Now we have a couple of resources. You
have very kindly provided this guest, which I
will share on the YouTube show notes when
the episode is finished.
This is a rough kind of playbook of
the things we're gonna cover today.
And at your recommendation, I have also configured
a GitHub organization
that we're gonna try and use for today's
examples.
So do you wanna
just explain? I the first thing I see
here is the first command we have to
do is g o t k bootstrap and
then a whole bunch of parameters.
What is this command going to do to
my cluster?
So the toolkit is composed out of a
CLI
that you can use to install, to bootstrap,
to configure, to debug what's happening on your
cluster,
and
and a bunch of controllers,
each with its own,
you know, scope. For example, we have a
controller that deals with sources like Git repositories
or Helm repositories or even s three buckets.
So you can add sources, remove sources, and
so on.
And there are other controllers as well. The
bootstrap command, what it does, it takes
an owner, let's say, a GitHub organization. You
pass it to GitHub organization and a repository
name, and it creates that repository for you.
If you have, let's say, teams inside your
your GitHub org, you can also tell it
which team teams should have access to this
repo. The repo is created by default private.
You can also create the repo public.
And what what's happening there,
the CLI will create the repo, will will
push to the repo the the toolkit
definition,
like the deployments, the customer resource definitions, and
so on,
applies them on the cluster, then it configures
that this particular repository
to be the source of truth for your
cluster.
And
what that means, it creates a deploy key.
It sets up the deploy key in your
GitHub repo, and then it's it starts to
listen to whatever is happening on your main
branch. So every time you do a commit
there, you change something even even the toolkit
definitions itself. So if you, let's say, run
the bootstrap command once, then in a couple
of weeks, you run it again,
it will not create a new repo. It
will see, okay, the repo is there, but
maybe the toolkit components
have advanced. When you version, it will do
an upgrade. And how it does the upgrade,
it just modifies the YAML inside your repo
and the toolkit itself upgrades it. It it
upgrades itself on the cluster.
Ah, very cool. That's about it.
Alright. So let's
let's just grab this command then.
And
I just need to make a few changes.
So my organization
is Rawkode
does get ops.
And I can just get this
any name, and this is gonna be created
for me. Right? That's Yeah.
I that go ahead and create a team
dev. So maybe we can talk about that
feature in a moment. And then the path
I'm assuming is
where it's gonna store a manifest in the
repository?
Yeah. So the the repository
created by Bootstrap is meant to be used
for your whole feed of clusters, not not
just one. So you can,
using the path, you'll say, hey. This particular
instance is for that path, and you can
use the cluster name for it. One one
use case for that is you may want
to test the toolkit upgrade on your staging
cluster before upgrading your production cluster and so
on. So the definitions are stored for each
cluster
separately.
Okay. Well, I like to live life on
the edge, so we'll call this my production
cluster.
And
return.
Oh, I got bad credentials already.
Bad credentials.
You need the
github underscore token
environment
variable set
before you I will quickly move that off
screen and check.
I have underscore token. Right?
Yep.
It's got a space in it.
Alright. Let's fix that.
Well, I wouldn't have thought that would have
caused the problem.
Put loads of text on my screen so
that when I move it back
yep. We don't reveal my token. Alright. I'm
gonna try that again.
There we go.
So We've got repository created.
It
oh, it's a wave of the world now.
Okay. It's created oh, no. It's at grant
anti granted
access to the dev team,
clone the repository,
generating some manifest, and then provisioning itself within
the cluster.
It's doing a lot for me. I don't
really need to do anything. Right? It just
Yeah. We with Flux, we've we've seen people
struggling with with the configuration.
So we said, okay. Let's use the GitHub
and GitLab APIs so we can streamline the
whole process with a with a single command.
We are looking at, I don't
people that have experience with Bitbucket. If you
know Bitbucket, if you are using it and
you are familiar with with Go,
yeah, we are looking for someone to help
us
add Bitbucket
implementation to the bootstrap command.
Now
maybe you are not running on any of
those SaaS
Git providers. So we we also have
instructions on how you can do the whole
thing manually.
You create the Git repo on your own,
then you generate the manifest, you push them,
and you set up the deploy key.
But, yeah, the boost rep command also
does a
sanity check of what's installed. So it it
checked all the controllers.
If you do, for example, kubectl
minus n
g o t k system,
get pods,
we'll see we have
four controllers here.
So
the source controller is the one that pulls
data from Git, Helm repositories,
s three buckets, and so on.
The notification controller is
a daemon that can listen
can listen to webhooks from
GitHub or GitLab or Jenkins or whatever.
So it can trigger
instant reconciliation inside your cluster.
It also
pushes notifications
from your cluster to, let's say, Slack, Microsoft
Teams, Rocket, and and other chat systems.
The customized
controller,
it's a controller that can work with customizations
or with plain YAML. So it applies that
on your cluster, does garbage collection for you,
health checking, and all sorts of things. And
health controller does the same stuff but for
health charts.
And that's
that's the toolkit.
Awesome.
So we got four controllers.
The notification controller,
immediately, is kind of interesting to me. So
it could push notifications to say that it's
updated something within the cluster. That was one
aspect of it. So that part was
it can lessen for web hooks coming from
GitHub,
GitLab, etcetera. So does it configure any of
those web hooks for me to push to
my cluster? Is that something that I need
to go ahead and and manually set up?
So there are a couple of custom resources,
which you
can use to configure,
things. One custom resource is called the receiver.
So it can create a receiver of type
GitHub,
and need to generate a unique URL that
you can use in your GitHub webhooks.
And it also gives you a secret
to check that
GitHub is really sending all those notifications
for
GitLab the same and so on.
So that's the receiver part when you can
define these kind of receivers and, you know,
you can suspend them, you can delete them,
and so on. And you can also create
alerts
for different providers. You can add, for example,
your Slack
channel there with API token, then you create
an alert and say, hey. If my,
I don't know,
my ContourHem
release is failing,
post the error message to this Slack channel
and so on. So there are custom resources
which you can define receivers and alerts.
Okay. Perfect.
So if we take a look at
my organization here, I'm curious about what's happened
on the GitHub side of this API then.
So we have this new repository here.
Okay. So it's created a directory with
the path that we provided.
And this is the YAML
for deploying itself.
Yeah.
Okay.
So if we look at the toolkit source.YAML
Yep.
Can you make that bigger?
I can.
There we go.
Yeah. So
this is how
a source gets
added on the cluster.
You give it the URL. In this case,
it's it's an SSH. It created already a
secret that contains the SSH public and private
and known host keys.
And using that particular secret, it now it
monitors the main branch of that URL.
Okay.
So every one minute, it's gonna check for
changes to that repository and then just apply
them to my cluster?
This particular object only pulls the
Oh, okay. Repo on the cluster. There is
a different object
customization.
And the customization object says, hey. From this
source,
name,
geo t k system,
apply the production path on the cluster.
And prune true means if you delete something
from inside the production directory, it will also
be deleted from from the cluster. So this
enable this this enables garbage collection, and this
is applied every ten sec ten minutes.
Okay.
So let me clarify those two intervals then.
Our get repository CRD is pulling changes every
one minute,
but the actual application of those changes is
on a ten minute schedule. Does that just
mean that if I push something to the
cluster multiple times before the ten minute starts,
the those all gonna apply to once?
No. No.
So
this interval here for the customization ten minutes,
what it does, it it applies
what what is found in the in the
repo at that particular path every ten minutes.
What that means is, let's say, goes into
the cluster,
has access to the cluster, modify something.
In a maximum of ten minutes, that modification
will be undone.
If it modify something in a toolkit itself,
let's say, it it configures,
it changes, I don't the limits,
those kind of changes will be unknown.
But if you push something to the repo,
in one minute, the source control will detect
that there is a change. And through Kubernetes
events, it notifies the customized control, hey. There
is a change. Don't wait ten minutes to
apply. Apply it now.
And if you are using a webhook, then
you don't even have to wait that one
minute because the webhook will issue Kubernetes event
source controller and say, hey. This webhook is
telling me there is a new there is
a new commit on the Git. Let me
pull it. If there is a change, then
it notifies the other controller, the other controller
will do the reconciliation.
So Okay. The difference between Flux and a
toolkit, the toolkit is is
reacts
to Kubernetes events. So it's also a reactive
system, not only a pool based system where
it does things only at a strict interval.
Got it. Okay. So the get repository interval
applies all the changes
on that schedule, and then this interval on
the customization is just really about fixing stuff
that people modify it manually. So I'm assuming
if
something extremely bad happened to my cluster and
I was making changes, I'd probably wanna change
that interval to be a bit more forgiving,
I guess.
No.
If you are dealing with an incident, you
probably want
to suspend this particular customization.
And there is a command for that. It's
GOTK suspend customization and name of the customization.
And what it does like a Kubernetes cron
job, it will never reconcile from that moment
on. So you can do whatever you want
on the cluster, fix it, then move your
changes into Git, commit those changes,
then resume the customization, and everything will be,
back to normal.
But in
the past, what people were doing were,
scaling to zero Flux.
We do not fight with you.
The the
thing that we've improved here,
maybe you have different things reconciling on your
cluster. Maybe you have optimization for your apps
and another optimization for your databases.
But if the incident is only affecting the
apps deployments,
then you shouldn't be stopping everything. Your whole
GitOps pipelines on on the cluster. Maybe you
want to stop that particular thing where where
the incident is happening. So
that's we don't have to scale to zero
anymore or anything.
Okay. So can we just type that command
here? Like, if I run g o t
k suspend
customization.
I'm just gonna keep following the docs assuming
I know what I'm doing here. And the
name of the resources
GOTK system is the name of them.
But that's no longer gonna get any updates.
That's it. That's nice. Okay. And
I can just I'm assuming change this to
resume.
Awesome.
Cool. I was I was if they tell
you what
revision it has applied. So it's the main
branch and that particular commit.
Okay. So I feel like then
we should deploy something
to our system.
Yeah. Good to hear.
So let's see.
Now what do you recommend?
So I'm sure I've seen that it cloned
something earlier or did I clone it and
the cluster size? I need to clone my
best repository.
Okay. Got it. Yeah.
Get ops, and let's open this up.
So
would I add a new directory here?
Yep. You can
from this moment on, you can organize however
you want your repo.
The toolkit is not in any way how
you want to
configure it.
The idea is if you want to target
your production cluster in this case,
all the definitions should be in in that
inside that directory. And you can use customized
overlays, hand releases, whatever you want.
Okay. Let's start nice and simple then.
And let's do
NGINX
Port.
Itty. Now I'm not gonna add a service
or anything. Let's just I just wanna apply
this as it is, and then we'll see
that relate to the cluster and then maybe
make a small revision or something. So
I would just they get add
million dollar application,
and then I just push this up to
my cluster up to GitHub,
and we wait
one minute.
Yeah. So we either wait one minute or
we can say,
g o t k source git
g o t k reconcile source git
source Git, and that's GOTK minus system.
I need to do it from this directory
because that's where my Kube config is.
Oh, do think it reconcile
source get POT? Reconcile.
Yeah. Type in is not my strong suit,
especially when I'm being watched. There we go.
So this is now
updated
everything inside of the cluster.
So if I run get pods
there we go.
That's easy. Now
you can also do geo t k get
customizations,
And it will show you the same
revision as the source.
So
it may happen that
you push a change,
that change gets pulled into the cluster, but
it doesn't get applied. Maybe there is an
error or
some new configuration, and
there will be a drift between
what it's supposed to be on the cluster
and what's really running on the cluster.
Right. Okay.
So
okay. Right. I get it. I get it.
Just thinking a load here.
What is
so I guess this is this is gonna
come down to where your experience is really
important here. Like,
what is the best way for this director
to be set up? Like, I what I
feel now is that I've made a a
mistake, storing my deployment NGINX inside of this
production folder. I feel like
would you start immediately with customize so that
you have bases and the ability to overlay
into environments?
Or,
you know, is this perfectly normal and it
get ups it get ups slow?
Well,
nobody
I cannot say, like, use customize. Maybe you
don't like it. Maybe you want to do
hand releases or other other things. Maybe you
want to, I don't know, generate all your
YAMLs with
JavaScript or, I don't queue or whatever and
commit commit the final YAMLs to to some
other repo. But I think for
for most people, customize should work really great
if you just want to do small changes
of your deployments across your fleet.
Customize has a downside in terms that you
cannot just, you know, use variables.
It doesn't do that. Right? So if you
want to set, for example,
the region name, and the region name will
be different
between clusters. And that region name is, I
don't know, somewhere in a config file or,
I don't back down below. Then you have
to, you know, teach customers how to patch
your things and so on. Maybe for that
use case, it's better to use a a
health chart and so on. But I
I like customize.
Okay. Yeah. Use it if you if you
can, but there are so many other options.
Okay. Do you see a a future for
Flux two or GetUp Toolkit where there's, like,
a controller for JSON,
controller for, you know, like, Carvel maybe, all
these other tools that do the same templating
responsibilities
as customized, but giving people a bit more
flexibility or choice, etcetera?
No. I don't think any of those tools
are
are meant to be reconcilers.
Those tools are meant to create YAML. So
you should if you want to use, let's
say, q or j or whatever, you can
you you can compile the final YAMLs in
your CI, validate them with something like Qvalve,
apply policies
with verify them with the
conf test, for example.
And
after all these things are okay, then you
should push the final YAML to a branch
and let the toolkit reconcile that branch.
I think the the faster you see the
YAML in Git, so you can do
diffs
and you can run this,
let's say, offline
validation,
is better than running all these tools inside
the cluster. And if the tool fails,
then you have to crawl logs and so
on. I think it's it's better to get
the final YAML earlier in your pipeline.
But that's not what customize is doing. Right?
I mean, we are running customized
and the cluster to produce the final YAML.
I mean, not in this example here, but
that's what this controller does. Or have I
completely missed the point here? So no. No.
No.
A customized controller uses customized
as a library
for many other things than just building a
customization. For example, it does an ordering using
customized. For example, custom resource definitions before
custom resources, namespaces before deployments and and stuff
like that. It also underneath
uses customized to label all your objects inside
the cluster. So if you want to say,
hey. For this particular customization, what kind of
objects have been created on the cluster? We
can use a label with the customization name,
and you'll you'll get a list of all
your things.
So, in a way, the the the customized
controller is using customized as
a library inside of it to to deal
with the reconciliation.
Maybe the name is not good is not
good. Maybe it should be, like, sync controller
or whatever.
But, yeah, I don't think you should create
a controller for any
templating
solution you have out there.
Okay.
Well, let's quickly bring in a couple of
questions then just I think that relate to
this. And I think you've potentially answered a
couple of them, but I'll I'll pop them
in anyway. So,
Elliot, I do see your first question. I'll
keep that one till the end because I
think that's interesting.
But I will pop in this one. Elliot
says, as a matter of personal preference, can
I not can I use it without customize?
And I think the answer there is
Yes. For sure.
The controller can can synchronize
plain YAMLs. It has
it's not operating that way. It doesn't need
the customization
dot YAML in your Git repo. It creates
one on the fly and adds labels and
all the things that it needs to do
to enable garbage collection, ordering, and all this
stuff.
Okay. And then he follows on with,
could one build their own custom
reconciler?
Of course.
We we intended for the toolkit to also
be an SDK
so you can build your own controllers on
top of the current API. And there is
a
development guide
that we've published on the docs website on
how you can build a controller with cube
builder that listens to a source controller events.
Fetch is the source that source controller has
pulled from all the sources, and then it's
up to you what you want to do
with that those manifests. Can be whatever.
I've seen people trying to to use source
control in CI systems where source control pulls
the source code from it.
Then there is a different controller that actually
does the build of that particular source and,
I don't pushes the
container image to to a registry. So
notification control and source control are not tied
in any way to the GitOps idea, like
like, continuous deployment. You can do a bunch
of other things with them if you want
to.
Excellent. One more question, and then we'll move
on with the the demo.
So we have a question saying, can I
use GetOp tool kit with subversion?
Not right now, but,
yeah, we've implemented
s three buckets part and the s v
SDN shouldn't be that hard if someone wants
to do it.
I guess with the get repository being as
one CRD, adding support for other
quote places locations, whether it be, you know,
Mercurial or subversion would just be a case
of adding on the CRD and the controller
to do the sync aspect of it. Yeah.
In our case, it's a you would add
a custom resource definition to the source control
API. Let's call it SVN
repository.
And then you'll be adding a controller to
a controller loop, source controller that deals with
that particular custom resource.
Excellent.
Cool. Let's jump back over to our demo
then. So what do you feel like the
next step is here? Should we add a
customized
basis
YAML,
or should we jump straight into Helm?
No. I would say let's let's show how
you can
add a different repository
to your cluster. Like, here in in this
example, we've added the deployment YAML directly to
our free triple.
But in normal cases, you you don't want
to do that. You want
let's say, if you are developing an application,
probably
somewhere in your app repo, there is a
deployment director or customized director or something like
that where you specify how your app
should be deployed.
And
the tool kit, what it tries to do
it it with with this custom resources, it
let you add let you add register
other sources inside the cluster and decide how
they are reconciled. So let's add
a different repository.
K. So I I can copy
this source and say I want to deploy
my other app.
And I
do have a previous one
here. So this is I was messing around
with
the get ups and I created some YAMLs
rendered from Helm that provisions on FluxCDB and
telegraph dot telegraph
daemon set. Okay.
I can the URL.
Yep.
And then
can I just use the public URL? Will
that work just fine?
Yep. So the git
repositories can can have an SSH URL. And
when you specify an SSH URL,
you are obliged to define the
SSH key for it.
If you use an HTTP address,
if that particular repo is public, you don't
have to,
configure any kind of authentication.
So
in this way, we let you add to
your cluster things from open source, like, I
don't know, if I'm having my own
open source project,
you can reconcile that particular
thing without having to clone it or anything
like that. If you trust me that I
will do, I don't know, sample releases and
groundbreaking changes, then you can actually add the
upstream to your cluster directly.
So, yeah, you can delete the secret ref.
So is
I think I just I'd like to clarify
something there then. So if I use a
public repository
in fact, no. If I use a private
repository and specify a secret ref,
I remember coming across something in the documentation
that talks about read only modes. So does
that mean there's a rate mode where the
GitOps toolkit modifies
my GET repository?
Yeah. In the future,
the GitOps toolkit will contain two more controllers.
One will scan container registries
and the other one, based on some policy
that you define,
will write back to your Git repo
when you push new
container images. Let's say
you have your own app
and you you push Sendware releases to your
registry instead of going every time and changing
the the new version inside your YAMLs. You
you could configure the toolkit and say, every
time there is a new Sendware release in
this particular range
on on Docker Hub, for example, get that
tag, write it back to Git, and some
other part of the system, the optimization control,
for example, will will apply.
Okay. Got it.
That makes sense. And I guess in read
only mode, does it would that as semantic
version and rules still be something that people
can consume? Does it use state within our
cluster to monitor those tags, or is that
still something that's to be determined right now?
So in in video in video only mode,
you can you
can tell the toolkit to follow similar releases
for a whole repository.
It doesn't look at container registry. So if
you version your YAML and you do SEMWARE
releases,
then the toolkit will be able to detect,
oh, there is a new release for on
that particular repository and you'll apply that release.
But with the container registry, it's more about
writing back
for each particular
container.
K. Got it.
Right. So I am assuming I do not
want to override
that. So we'll call this custom repo in
line with the directory.
With regards to interval, I mean, one minute
seems like quite a sensible option.
If I were to do one second, I
mean, is that likely to cause problems?
Could be. I I don't think it will
actually work. I think it will not work.
It will set something like ten seconds or
We can go for a minute and do
that manual reconciles step. Okay.
So if I save this.
No. No. No. No. No. Wait.
Alright.
Let let's let's see above if there is
something else in this file.
Oh, no. It's only this. Okay. That should
work.
K. Can can
commit this one.
Alright. So we're adding a second repository.
Push this.
And then we can do
reconcile here just to speed it up.
So I guess I'm gonna assume if I
do geo case system get get repositories.
I like it when things are just intuitive.
So
master main
error here, I'm assuming.
Yeah. This one has been updated.
So
it's
it's correct
branch.
Reconcile one more time
and
there we go.
That's now fetching
the other get repository,
applying that to the cluster
so I can run get
pods.
Don't see anything.
Yeah. You just declared the source. Now what
you should be doing is that source.
That's correct.
See? I'm glad you're here.
So I
need to
and tell her to apply it.
So that's
Yeah. You can start in the same. Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
K.
So we want custom
repo.
No. There you should say what you are
actually
trying to do here.
In FluxCDB.
Maybe it's a better name because you are
applying in FluxCDB.
K. Then the
source rep should be your custom repo.
I wish I had named that better now,
but I'm stuck with it. So
So I've seen you had, like, two directories.
Are those independent things, or they have to
be applied?
Yes. So there,
I guess, what you're suggesting there is I
could have a customization to apply each of
these individually,
or I could just do a dot apply
everything recursively.
That can well, both of those work?
Yeah.
And
you can also do
dependency management for let's say, for example,
you don't want to install in FluxCDB if
Telegraph is not there
or the other way around.
So you can, for example, define two customizations
for each directory and say for the Telegraph
one that depends on the influx DB one.
And what the customized control do will will
build the dependency graph before it does the
apply of your Git repo and applies the
things in a particular order based on the
dependency relationship
between those.
K. That's that's where it go.
Yeah. Why why we implemented that particular feature
is because of
admission webhooks and service matches.
Like, I'll give you an example. If you
if you install
a service match,
then you install your apps. Everything is good.
When your app will be installed, if the
service mesh is already there, it will get
injected with the sidecar and it will function
great.
But GitOps is meant to to work
when you, let's say, bootstrap cluster from scrap
a cluster from scratch. Let's say you lost
your cluster or you want to build an
identical cluster.
Now if you apply all the things in
your Git repo
in in the same
operation like Flux version one does,
there is a great chance that your app
port will start before, let's say, the linker,
the injector or the yeast injector.
Right? And your app will start, will have
no sidecar,
and
many problems from there because, well, it's not
meshed and it's meant to be meshed.
With the toolkit, you can say,
all my apps depend on this
infrastructure
customization that can contain InstaLink or the gatekeeper,
OPA, or any other stuff that needs to
be there before
applications
get
get provisioned. And in
using the dependency tree, you can reliably,
you know, clone clusters, create identical clusters, and
it'll happen in that particular order.
Okay. That makes sense.
So just to make sure I understood that
correctly,
to use the dependencies,
I need to define each of these separately.
Right? Yeah.
And
then I'm configuring the path here and changing
the name.
Yes. And now inside this Yep.
Sorry. On you go. Inside the spec, now
you can add the
depends on
entry
with oh, k. Depends on, and now it's
name to point
name. The list of objects? Yeah. Okay.
Yes. And it should be in FluxCD.
That's it? That's it?
I like it when things are this simple.
Okay.
So that looks okay to me. I'm sure
there's probably a mistake, but
What's yeah. It should tell us
it should tell us everything is going wrong.
Okay. So we're now going to apply
influx DB and telegraph with dependencies.
We can reconcile.
And I'm assuming
I can run get customizations
like we did earlier.
Oh, we're in the correct namespace.
We gotta oh, so it's not ready yet.
So we can see right away that it's
not deployed to Telegraph daemon set because it's
waiting on our influx DB containers to become
healthy.
It's currently pending.
And there's Telegraph.
Yeah.
One thing we should have done was to
create a health check on InfluxCD. Like, what
what we've done right now is that we
are configuring the tool kit to apply first
InfluxCD
then that. But that doesn't mean that in
FluxCDB is actually running. Right? You apply it,
then it can take forever
to spin up the pods.
What what we can do is add
a health check entry to the customization and
specify, hey. Look for the deployment named or
in this case is a stateful set.
Look for the stateful set, InfluenceDB,
and
check it if that is healthy. And only
then
allow all the other
depends on relation to go to go for
a reconcile.
Going back to the
to the service mesh example,
you can apply link ID, but that doesn't
mean that the injection webhook is up and
healthy for your pods to be injected. So
you can
we you can use health checks in in
this particular way to make sure that everything
is running before
nothing else. So
Okay. So
I do have an error, but that's my
mistake because
I haven't configured
actually
any PVC options on this cluster. So I'm
just gonna ignore influx DB for now. But
to confirm what you were seeing there, if
if my
state will set here
had a oh, no. It does have health
hit. So how do I connect that up
then?
So there is in in the customization of
the influx DB,
you can add your health check entry.
I can pull up the docs. It's
ops tool kit.
K. If you go to toolkit components,
customize controller,
customization,
custom resource definition,
and health health assessment is on your right.
Yep.
Can you see there?
Cool. Oh, yeah. So we tell the object
that we are looking for to be healthy,
the namespace, the name. Alright. Got it.
So
okay. So let's
I want to remove this. We have prune
enabled. So I'm assuming if I just comment
all of this out and push this up,
it will prune them away.
So I'm gonna do that first.
I like it when things go wrong because
then I learn how to fix it. So
remove influx DB and telegraph.
That'll get add.
There you go.
And
because we have prune on,
when I run the reconcile, it's gonna remove
those from
in the by Rawkode pods.
There we go. Terminating and unboxed d p
is already gone.
You should also remove
the oh, this is in the default namespace.
Yeah. If you'd have had the namespace definition
inside your, let's say, in FluxCDB manifest,
it will first, what it does, it goes
through all the namespace
objects.
So it will remove deployments, custom resources, and
so on. After all of all of those
are gone, then it will remove
cluster level objects, like namespaces,
like cluster or bindings, and so on. Why
we
do this kind of garbage collection is for
custom resources to be finalized.
Otherwise,
you could get into a stuck state where
you delete a custom resource. It needs to
be finalized by something, but you already deleted
that something. So your main pages and everything
else will be stuck. So we we try
to
to play nice with
with other controllers and
do the deletion in
different steps.
Okay.
Excellent.
So
what's the best way for me to use
those health checks? I'm gonna bring Telegraph back
in,
but we don't have a satisfied dependency here.
Yeah. Can remove it, and you can add
the health check for for Telegraph itself.
How okay. So we're removing the dependency.
And you want me to apply this as
is?
Sorry. I don't understand what you were suggesting.
I was suggesting to add the health check
for the telegraph demo set,
if you want to do that. Oh, in
fact, together okay. There's
let's let's let's change this a little bit.
So we already have this engine x deployment
here.
So if I just add a health check
to the to aliveness probe or readiness probe
to this,
if I just copy them from here,
then we can have telegraphs only will only
get deployed if that is healthy.
So let me add this.
And we'll just do it there because engine
x will respond it's gonna respond by a
oh, okay. Okay.
This is fine. I shouldn't make this stuff
up. Okay. Let's go into GitOps.
What I'm gonna do is add
our production engine x and deploy that first.
Add probes to engine x.
Let me do a reconcile,
and then if I run on this,
we have our new engine x spinning up
and it should become healthy. I'll wait till
I see one zero one.
Yes. I didn't add those probes correctly.
See if I can quickly fix this or
just move on.
Oh, okay. No. It's not a named port.
My bad.
So let's add that one more time.
We use my commit message, which I I
know I shouldn't do, but
I'll do it for now.
And let's get
get part.
It's it's now got a probe on it.
So
in order to demonstrate the health checks, let's
come back to here, bring back our telegraph
d s,
and add our depends
on
name,
and this is the customization
Geotrigo system.
Geotrigo. Thank you.
We're also gonna add a health
check. I'll I'll just copy this from the
docs.
No.
So let's think about it. You want to
make the
deployment
depend on another
object, right, another thing in your infrastructure.
So you'll be creating the health check
on the customization that creates NGINX.
Right? Yes.
Then you'll say, hey. All the things that
I'm trying to add afterwards
have to
be reconciled only if that
the GitOps GeoTK system
customization actually works. Right? So the health check
will go on the GeoTK system customization file.
Okay. So the health checks cannot
they don't they have to reference resources created
within its own customization?
No.
No. But
you should. Right?
Okay. So You can you can define health
checks in optimization that reference whatever in your
infrastructure even if it it doesn't come from
a Git repo. But the idea of a
dependency is that you define all these checks
on object that creates them, and then all
the other things will wait for that.
If you define the health check on your,
demand set there,
what what the customer has control will do,
we'll apply
the thing, and then we'll check if it's
healthy. What you want to do is do
not apply the thing if
if, I don't know, the the health check
is failing for another personalization. Makes sense?
Ah, okay. So I got that completely wrong
then. I thought
okay, I thought the health check here
was gonna say don't deploy this customization
unless this resource is healthy.
But that's not what it's doing at all.
No.
Right. Sorry. I completely misunderstood that. Got it.
That make okay. That makes much more sense
to me now.
Whoops.
Okay. So let's not bother with the health
check on this.
Well, yeah, we're doing a health check but
for Telegraph. Well, there are no probes on
it. So
let's just take it out. Okay.
So let's let's
just apply this and then we can move
on.
So
add
telegraph
then.
Shall we take a look at the helm
controller,
or is there anything that I've maybe missed
here that you'd like to cover?
Other than me, just not understanding anything so
far, but that's okay.
Mhmm.
No. It's okay. It's a
it's a learning process because we we added
all these
things that you can do and yeah. I
I can understand how health check can be
confusing. There are
two roles to health checks.
The role on the customization itself is you
apply something and then you want to be
notified if that particular something worked or not.
That's
one use case. Right?
Then
when you create a dependency tree, all the
dependents
if you have defined health checks
on your customization, all the dependents will be
blocked on those particular health checks. So, for
example, you will not be deploying your app
if the linker, the injector is failing because
app will not be injected. That's one example.
Another example is don't apply any YAML if
the gatekeeper,
deployment is failing because you want to ensure
that
everything that,
gets changed on your cluster
is approved by your OPA,
policy agent. Right? And for that to work,
the policy agent has to run.
So
yeah.
Okay. So, I mean, I guess the the
only mistake I was really making there was
is this depends on is gonna is is
gonna wait until this engine actually source exists.
And then I was gonna add a health
check here to check the health of this.
But, really, what you've just said there is
what I should have done is add the
health check
Yep. Here.
Ah, okay. So I've I've actually I had
that wrong in my head twice.
So really, if I had just added that
we have a deployment called engine x and
the default namespace,
and
my
telegraph wouldn't have been deployed until
this was actually healthy.
Yeah. Okay.
Makes sense. Got it. Finally.
Okay. Let's take a look at the the
helm integration then. So right now, we have
a GetOps pipeline that has two repositories. One
managing the GetOps toolkit system, one managing our
million dollar application, which is nice and trivial.
It's just some telegraph stuff.
If I then want to add something from
Helm,
like,
MariaDB,
MongoDB, some sort of database to
How much the best way to deploy that?
What are my first steps to doing that?
So
first step, you have to define
where is your chart,
where is that particular HEM repository.
Right? And
the same way you define a Git repo,
you can define a Helm repo.
And if you scroll down here,
for example, here, we add the Bitnami
repository.
Okay. So we are using g o t
k create source. We're telling it as Helm
and not GET, and then we just specify
the Bitnami
repository.
Yeah. Which is public. If you have a
Henry poetry that's
private, you can also give here in the
command the
username and password or token of your
register repository.
Okay. So if I go into my get
up director here,
we were feeling
brave. So
production.
We were I was feeling brave. This is
my production.
And then we deploy
this.
That's gonna create oops.
But, Naomi,
we've got our kind Helm repository
called, Naomi, with this chart.
And then
we okay. So this is just generating the
YAML to create a namespace.
Yeah. So one one particularity
of our Helm controller
is the fact that helm controller only installs
charts. It doesn't create anything
beside what's in the
helm chart
package.
And you shouldn't be placing namespaces,
for example, in your charts.
So
this is where helm controller, customized control work
great together with with the customized control. The
customized control will create namespace definitions, which should
be in your fleet repo or your cluster
repo.
And then we'll apply helm release
manifests and those
you can tell those, hey. I want this
particular helm chart to be installed in that
particular namespace.
Okay.
So let's
grab this and then generate this. And then
in fact, what I'll do is just next
to this,
v one
kind namespace
rather than just doing the command
on tour.
And then
exit
Action. So we're using semantic version in here
to deploy
a version two verse
v two contour.
You tell it the helm repository name, which
we just created. We give it a release
name, the target name space, which I just
added to the YAML.
And the and after export, you should be
creating the contour YAML log by the thing.
Yep.
So
So we should have this here.
Perfect.
So my my first question here is
how do I customize the chart with values?
So here you can type values.
As part of the spec? Yes.
That's the chart spec. No. Part of the
header link spec.
This is just an an object where I
could see my
one,
two, three, four. Yep.
So these are
those values specify here will override
the
values dot YAML from your help chart and
can do other things like I want
values to be fetched from a Kubernetes secret.
Let's say some charts,
yeah, I have to pass in, I don't
know, username, passwords, tokens, and so on. You
don't want to place your
tokens
your secrets here in plain text in your
Git repo.
So you can use something like Mozilla SOAPs
or seal secrets to manage Kubernetes secrets in
a GitOps way. And then here,
in in values, instead of saying value token
something, you'll say values from
this particular secret.
And what helm controller will do will take
the secret from your that lives inside your
cluster and merge the values in your secret
with the values you specify here. So here,
you should only set values that are not
secrets. Alright? Not secrets. Okay.
That I definitely understand.
But to find the values is quite easy.
So I can just add
all of this
and
add it contour
via helm
and push.
And if we run our reconcile one more
time,
See.
Oh, there. Our names our namespace is ten
seconds old, so maybe I was just a
bit quick.
There you go. We now have Contour running
deployed via Helm
via the CRD and get ups to look
at It will create many other ports. Right
now, it it's just a it spins up
the third generation, and then it'll spin up
an Envoy, a demand set, and the Contour
ports, which are the control plane of of
the ingress controller.
But yeah. And
with with Helm, you can do several things.
For example, here, what what we are doing
is using delegation.
If you go back, for example, to the
the Helm release definition,
you'll see that there is a target namespace
there.
So what I'm doing here, I'm placing the
helm release definition in my system namespace, JLTK
system. Let's say no one has access except
for cluster admins to that particular namespace.
And I want to provision some infrastructure
for a particular team. And I can use
target namespace
to say, hey. I'm declaring the hand release
here because I don't want anyone
else to be able to modify what cluster
admins. I don't want installed
in the same namespace where the hand release
is defined. I want to install it in
that particular namespace.
And this gives cluster
admins the power provision things in in other
teams' namespaces or tenants'
namespaces.
And,
yeah,
no one can modify that original object.
Alright. Excellent.
Let's jump back over here.
So
we've covered Helm,
and this was just another
good example.
We
we have an add on for for the
GitHub toolkit that's
composed of Prometheus and Grafana.
And we have instrumented the controllers, so have
an overview of what's happening on the cluster,
and here is how you can deploy the
monitoring stack.
We are currently
developing more
adding more metrics to to our controller. So
in the next release, you'll be able to
set up, for example, other manager,
say, hey. When a reconciliation fails, send me
an alert based on some metric that
I don't customized control is failing to reconcile
influx DB in the last half hour or
something like that.
We we have the notification controller, which files
all these
alerts to
Slack, Microsoft Teams, so on. But other manager
has so many
back ends that knows how to deal with
them. Don't PagerDuty and
the lots of it. And we we don't
think notification control is the only answer to
other things, so that's why we've
we we are going to add metrics.
So you can use Prometheus and other manager
to do
things like that and also build nice dashboards
so you can see all the customization with
their status,
how long does it take to do a
reconciliation,
and if it failed or not, and so
on.
This is, let's say,
our
graph on our dashboard collection that will be
shipping.
And maybe in the future, we'll have a
full blown user interface.
But for now, we'll try we try to
have, like, top touch graph on our dashboards
so we can see what's going on.
Oh, very cool.
Well, I will add this. I think I
think these steps here are fantastic for kinda
covering everything that we've already been through today.
So people can follow along with us in
their own time and deploy their own get
ups toolkit.
What I will do is I'm sorry. Sorry.
I have an else you want to demo
before I stop sharing my screen, or do
you think we've we've covered most of the
things that you want to take over? Yeah.
I I think we we've covered the basics.
The idea is that with with the toolkit
compared to FluxCD one, we let you
define your cluster state from multiple sources, and
then you decide how those sources
are going to be reconciled.
If you want to add health checks, if
you want to add garbage collection, if you
want to spend or resume them,
depending on if you have an incident or
not.
All these things come from future requests and,
things that we've seen for FluxCD one, what
our users
wanted more more stuff, and, yeah, we we
added them to the toolkit.
Yeah. I I think it's a very powerful
set of tools. I'm really impressed with just
how quickly and easy it was for us,
you know, to bootstrap the system, start adding
our own get sources,
and then applying it to the cluster. And
the Helm integration there was
so trivial.
Really, really impressive. Just the ergonomics of of
working with GetOps is nice. I really like
it.
Yeah. For for Helm, we have many other
things that you can configure in that particular
Helm Helm release. For example,
we
you can trigger Helm tests
after
a chart is installed or upgraded. And based
on the result of the test, you can
roll back to the previous version. Let's say
you are running on 100.
You bump it to 200. It fails. The
help test failed. Or the
native help
help check fails, like the deployment is stuck
or a stateful set is stuck. You can
tell help controller, if that one fails, roll
it back and let me know.
So you end up with with the previous
state
that should be fine, and you get a
notification. Hey. Your help test failed. This is
why it failed, and we we roll it
back for you.
And that's that's one feature of of help
control that we've added recently.
Oh, very cool.
So we have one more question
that we skipped over earlier, but I think
now would be a good time to cover
it. And then we can maybe talk about
what's coming down the line, and then I'll
let you get back to your day.
But earlier left a question earlier, and he
was asking
about Rancher's new product called Fleet and how
that really compares to GetUp Toolkit.
His specific question is Fleet seems to be
designed for scale,
and how does that compare to what GetOp's
Toolkit is doing as it meant for a
very specific use case?
We are working on integrating the the toolkit
with
cluster API.
So our our approach is a little bit
different from what Rancher and OpenShift
and others are doing. Instead of managing everything
for from the management cluster and
make that management cluster a single point of
failure.
What we are trying to do is
when you bootstrap clusters, you'll be adding cluster
definitions in your git.
You install the GitOps toolkit on your management
cluster.
Then
the toolkit will will discover that, okay, a
new cluster has been created. Toolkit will be
able to provision itself on that particular cluster
with the repo that you you assigned to
it.
And then even if the management cluster goes
down, I don't know, runs into trouble,
all these, clusters will be able to keep,
keep working, keep synchronizing with their own Git
repos.
And
in a way, the the our GitOps approach
is more distributed than, you know, having everything
on a management cluster and drive all the
operations from a single point.
But you'll be you'll also be able to
do that with the toolkit if you want
to.
Customized controller has a feature where it can
mount an existing
KubeConfig from a secret.
So for example, many
copy providers
will create a KubeConfig for each cluster they
have created.
And you can tell a customize, hey. Reconcile
this source,
but not locally
use this particular to config. And it will
connect to that cluster and and do its
job. So we we are trying to cover
cover both,
things where from the management cluster, you apply
everything. Or from the management cluster, you you
boost up your clusters, and then they can
run on their own with no single point
of failure.
So, yeah, I think our approach is very
different from what Rancher is doing.
Yeah. And very exciting to me. I I'm
really enjoying my exploration with the cluster API
right now and with GetOp Toolkit. And now
you're pushing both of these together and giving
me this workflow that will allow me to
have GetOp Toolkit on my management cluster,
bootstrap itself, and then go into its own
reconciliation loop, which is really exciting. I'm looking
forward to playing with that in the future.
Yeah. I think another
use case is for
adding, installing
the cluster add ons after you bootstrap a
cluster. So it can you have can have,
like, a generic Git repo with all your
cluster add ons there. Right? And you can
tell the toolkit, hey. When after we could
create a cluster
and you you see that the QConfig was
created, it works, can connect it, install these
add ons from this repo
at this particular revision.
And you can send where your
cluster add ons, make releases out of it,
and and the tool kit will will keep
updating your fleet based on that.
So the idea of a multi repository gives
you this freedom of saying, want dedicated repo
with only cluster add ons and and maybe
other repos with, I don't know, other things
like
user applications and stuff like that.
Awesome. I look forward to that update coming
down the line.
So I just wanna say thank you for
spending the last hour and fifteen minutes walking
us through GetOps toolkit.
And like I said, I it's just really
impressive how easy it was to get started
and start deploying things to your cluster. So
thank you for your continued work on this.
It's really cool to see it. Thank you
very much, David, for for inviting me. And
yeah. I hope by
next next year, we'll do another round, and
it'll be, like,
full blown KP support. Next
year, I'm gonna schedule you on every month
to follow the updates, I think. I'll just
keep harassing your calendar till you finally get
in and see. Yes. But
alright. Well, thank you again for joining me.
It's been a pleasure. A video will be
available online. All of the show notes will
be available in roughly an hour. And thanks
again, and I'll speak to you all soon.
Have a good day, Stefan. Bye.